An der Langstrasse hast du eigent-
lich jeden Tag so einen Kreislauf.
Die Leute
gehen abends in den Ausgang,
konsumieren ohne Ende.
Ich merke,
dass ich da nicht dazugehöre.
Ich möchte nicht mehr Teil
dieses sinnlosen Abendkonsums sein,
sondern Teil einer Bewegung,
die nach vorne schaut.
Trotzdem
ist es ein sehr schönes Quartier.
Eine grosse Herzensangelegenheit.
Ich bin Carla (27) und wohne
mitten in der Stadt Zürich,
an der Langstrasse.
Ich mache im Moment die Matur
und bin ursprünglich Schneiderin.
Und ich lebe Minimal Waste.
Minimal Waste heisst für mich,
dass ich auf möglichst alles
verzichte, was unnötig ist.
Sprich: Ich kaufe nichts in Plastik.
Ich brauche keinen Halm,
um meinen Drink zu schlürfen.
Ich hatte am Anfang grossen Respekt
vor solchen Sachen wie Zahnpasta
oder Deo auszuwechseln.
Anstatt
einer konventionellen Zahnpasta
benutze ich Kokosnussöl
und Aktivkohle.
Das Kokosnussöl ist
antimikrobakteriell und antifungal.
Es ist toll für alles.
Die Aktivkohle
wirkt ganz leicht abrasiv.
Für ein Rouge
benutze ich ein Randenpulver.
Wenn ich mich schminken will,
mache ich es nass
und streiche es auf die Wangen.
Im Sommer ist mein Deo etwas mühsam:
Kokosnussöl schmilzt ja
ab einem gewissen Punkt.
Jetzt, da es so heiss ist, sowieso.
Aber es geht eigentlich ums Natron,
das im Deo enthalten ist.
Es verhindert,
dass sich Bakterien bilden können.
Du kannst ein bisschen herausnehmen
und dir unter die Achseln streichen.
Es funktioniert
wie ein normales Deo,
aber es bekämpft nicht die Symptome
des Stinkens, sondern die Ursache.
Es entstehen keine Bakterien,
die dann stinken können.
Es gibt natürlich auch Sachen,
die du vorrätig hast aus der Zeit,
bevor du damit begonnen hast.
Ich schätze,
es dauert ein bis eineinhalb Jahre,
bis du all diese Sachen
ausgemustert hast,
also bevor du
mit all deinen Sachen fertig wirst.
Das ist am Anfang recht mühsam,
weil du denkst,
du kommst nicht vorwärts.
Aber du musst sozusagen
über den Berg.
Es dauert sehr lange,
aber es ist okay.
Ich kaufe alles offen ein.
Dann bringe ich es in Taschen
nach Hause
und fülle es in meine Gläser ein.
Somit habe ich halt
keine Verpackung,
sprich ich habe keinen Abfall.
Dort,
wo der Abfall normalerweise ist,
stehen bei mir Küchenmaschinen.
Es ist noch lustig:
Die Leute
gehen automatisch zur Spüle.
Dort suchen sie den Abfall.
Ich sage dann:
"Okay, nein, du darfst es
in dieses Glas legen."
Dann sind sie sehr irritiert,
aber es ist halt ...
Ich habe keinen Abfall mehr,
sondern nur noch ein Glas.
Und das ist gut so.
Ich will das nicht.
Das ist etwa der Abfall
eines Monats.
Und vieles, was da drin ist,
ist Recyclingabfall.
Also so ...
Das stammt z.B. vom Zucker.
Ähm ... Linsen.
Manchmal gönnt man sich Linsen.
Dann ein Stück Holz.
So!
Die etwa ...
Wie viele?
Die etwa sieben Male,
als ich vergass zu sagen:
"Könnte ich den Eiscafe oder Eistee
ohne Halm und Schnickschnack haben?"
Solche Trinkhalme
regen mich total auf.
Ich nehme sie jeweils mit
und denke mir:
"Ich benutze sie
wenigstens noch einmal."
"Dann habe ich nicht nur one way."
Dann: Das ist eine Body Lotion,
die ich vorher hatte
und die jetzt endlich
aufgebraucht ist.
Das ist mein altes Parfüm.
Das habe ich mal mit 18 bekommen.
Es ist neun Jahre alt geworden.
Aber jetzt kommt es weg.
Ich komme nicht darum herum,
Sachen zu wiegen und dann
diese Sticker vom Wiegen zu haben -
ausser,
ich hole die Sachen beim Bauern.
Aber ich habe weder ein Auto, noch
sind die Bauern gut erreichbar.
Ähm ...
Und dadurch ist es wie ...
Eben: Bei gewissen Dingen
kommst du nicht darum herum.
Das ist okay. Es wäre schön,
wenn es andere Optionen gäbe,
aber sich deswegen zu stressen,
ist nicht nötig.
Diese schöne Tonne ist Kompost.
Ähm ...
Es ist wie ...
Wenn du dir den Abfall
in der Schweiz anschaust,
sind 30 % von dem, was wir in die
Kehrichtverbrennung schicken, Essen.
Das ist ein Wurmkompost.
Ähm ...
Jetzt können wir dieses Element
eigentlich wegnehmen.
Da bewegen sie sich.
Das Ziel ist eigentlich, dass aus
deinen Lebzeiten nichts zurückbleibt
und wenn ich mal gehe,
alles mit mir zergehen kann -
so wie ich zu Erde werde,
alles andere zu Erde wird.
Ich habe meistens
einen dieser Metallteller dabei,
einen Becher ...
... und Besteck.
Und wenn ich keins dabeihabe,
frage ich im nächsten Restaurant,
ob ich eine Gabel leihen darf.
Die Leute sind eigentlich easy
und offen.
Serviette und das Portemonnaie.
Ich stelle es da rein.
Der Becher.
Es ist sicher jeden Tag
auch etwas Struggle dabei,
aber es macht so
auch viel zufriedener,
denn ich weiss:
Ich bin nicht part of this shit.
Guten Appetit!
- Danke!
Anina hat einen Blog
über Nachhaltigkeit und Ethik.
Ich nehme gerne
eine Portion Vegane Momos.
Und ich gerne die Veggie-Momos.
Darf ich sie auf dem Teller haben?
- Natürlich!
Und deines ist sogar isoliert.
- Ja.
Das ist noch cool.
Danke vielmals!
- Bitte!
Du beginnst,
dein Umfeld zu optimieren.
Du bist in der Stadt
ganz klar ein Exot.
Das bewegt.
Es ist etwas,
das anders ist und Einfluss hat.
Verglichen mit dem, was ich mache,
ist sie nochmals krasser ein
Spezialist fürs Thema Minimal Waste,
wie sie es nennt.
Und ich fand es sehr toll,
dass meine Community auch mal
die Insights von jemandem bekommt,
der das wirklich stark lebt.
Ich glaube,
man muss schon sehr engagiert sein,
damit man das von einem Tag auf
den anderen alles umsetzen könnte.
Ich sage auch den Leuten, die z.B.
auf vegan umstellen möchten:
Schritt für Schritt ist einfacher,
sodass man sich nicht
mit Erwartungen überfordert,
die man fast nicht erfüllen kann.
Ich sage immer "Minimal Waste".
Es ist nicht der Anspruch,
perfekt zu sein.
Das Ziel ist,
seine beste Option zu finden.
Und das kannst du überall machen.
Es gibt so viele kleine Sachen,
die man verändern kann.
* Sanfte Musik *
So, jetzt nehmen wir noch ...
... ein paar Kerne fürs Müesli
am Morgen.
Dann kannst du dir mit dem Stift -
wie früher in der Schule -
auf die Hand schreiben.
487 g Kerne.
Das ist Natron.
Das ist ein Teil meines Deos.
Es lässt die Bakterien nicht zu,
also die Entstehung von Bakterien.
Die Leute sind noch nicht
so sensibilisiert darauf,
dass es auch unverpackt
möglich wäre.
Und sie sehen halt den Aufwand,
den man im Moment betreiben muss.
So!
Ja.
Den nehme ich mit.
Ich glaube, ohne so einen Laden
Zero Waste zu leben,
wäre viel mühsamer.
Aber wo ein Wille ist,
ist auch ein Weg.
Irgendwie würde es schon gehen.
Vielleicht müsste ich
ein paar Kompromisse mehr eingehen.
Aber ich muss mir diese Gedanken
gar nicht machen,
denn ich habe einen solchen Laden.
Es gibt in Zürich keine Ausrede.
Auf diesem Weg
zu möglichst wenig Verschwendung
bin ich ziemlich nahe bei Tara,
glaube ich.
Sie ist ein bisschen mein Vorbild.
Sie führt den "Zero Waste"-Laden.
103 g Natron.
Natron braucht man immer.
Wie?
- Natron braucht man immer.
Diese "Zero Waste"-Geschichte
inspiriert ja auch
und sucht nach Lösungen.
Und das ist ziemlich toll.
Ich denke, dass wir im Herbst
Tofu im Glas anbieten können.
Dann ist das schon wieder
ein Schritt - ah, toll!
Wieder eine Plastikverpackung
weniger!
16.65 Fr.
- Mit der Karte.
Mit der Karte?
Ich glaube, finanziell gesehen
ist es eine Mischrechnung.
Früher konsumierte ich
sehr viele Kleider
und kaufte günstige Lebensmittel.
Jetzt hat sich das gedreht:
Ich konsumiere sehr wenige Kleider,
aber meine Lebensmittel
sind definitiv teurer.
* Popmusik *
Ich bin hier beim NOERD-Sommerfest,
bei dem es um Zero Waste geht.
D.h.,
die Veranstalter gaben sich Mühe,
dass hier möglichst wenig
Verschwendung stattfindet.
Ich mache mich auf die Suche
nach Tara, die das organisiert.
* Popmusik *
Hallo!
Hallo! Wie geht's dir? Gut?
Du musst immer Boni sagen.
- Das ist auch gut.
Hi!
# You know you want more.
# Less perial.
Es ist immer total schön,
die Fühler
nach Produkten auszustrecken,
die man vielleicht noch nicht hat
und spannend findet.
Schau, das ist der Kompost,
den ich habe!
* Sanfte Musik *
In diese Richtung wollen wir gehen,
oder?
Die Zahnpasta mache ich immer
aus Kokosöl und Aktivkohle.
Ja.
Nein, die machst du selber.
Nein.
Ich habe auch keines mehr gekauft,
wie du siehst.
Ja, aber das ist auch das,
was mir am meisten fehlt.
Dass es das nicht gibt,
nervt mich am meisten.
Ich hatte fünf Jahre lang
blaue Haare.
Sie wurden zu meinem Markenzeichen.
Und jetzt ist so wie der Punkt,
an dem ich sage:
"Wenn ich mir den Berg
an Plastikdosen vorstelle,
den ich benutzen müsste,
um ein Leben lang
blaue Haare zu haben,
haut es mich um."
Es ist total cool!
- Ja, nicht wahr?
Und das Schöne ist, dass es
eine Verbindung zwischen Genuss,
Stil und Lösungsorientierung ist.
Das ist auch das,
was man aufzeigen muss oder will:
Ein nachhaltiges Leben
oder ein umweltfreundlicher Alltag
haben ganz viel mit Genuss, Stil und
gut designten Lösungen usw. zu tun.
Ja.
Ich glaube,
die Leute interessiert es sehr -
die Stände, die wir hier haben.
Ich glaube,
sie haben sehr gute Gespräche.
Man sieht ein paar Fails.
Es ist trotzdem Plastik da.
Oder es werden plötzlich
Ballone verteilt.
Ja.
- Mit solchen Sachen muss man leben.
Und wir lernen daraus.
Es ist wie so ...
Es ist auch ein Experiment.
Ich glaube,
dass wir nicht darum herumkommen,
in Zukunft
Lösungen finden zu müssen.
Dass es jetzt schon Leute gibt,
die dafür brennen,
daran interessiert sind
und aktiv Lösungen suchen,
zeigt ja eigentlich,
dass wir die Kurve
hoffentlich noch bald kriegen.
Bis bald,
wenn ich mal nicht verkabelt bin!
* Lachen *
Viel Spass noch!
- Danke! Ciao!